Salut tout le monde,
j'espère que vous allez bien.
Alors, aujourd’hui je voulais vous parler
à nouveau de Laurie
que j'avais rencontrée sur la colline du crack.
Alors, pour ceux qu'ont pas suivi
l’histoire depuis le début,
je vous invite à aller voir les trois précédents épisodes qu'il y a eu sur YouTube.
Je vous mets les liens en description.
Alors, Laurie,
je l'ai suivie pendant deux ans.
D'abord sur la colline
lorsqu'elle était dépendante au crack
et qu'elle se prostituait.
Si t'es du côté d'Aubervilliers,
si t'as 50 balles,
et ben on baise et on se voit, voilà.
C'est tout, y a pas de longue histoire.
Pourquoi tu toques dans les tentes toi ?
Fils de pute, là.
Et ensuite, chez sa mère en Belgique
quand elle est tombée enceinte.
Je suis en Belgique, chez ma maman.
Parce que j’attends un bébé.
Alors, Laurie, elle a complètement arrêté
le crack depuis, elle est retournée à Paris,
vivre avec sa fille dans un hôtel social
et beaucoup de choses
ont changé dans sa vie.
Tu commences à filmer ?
- Ben... Je fais quoi ?
- T'inquiète.
Tu peux nous expliquer ce qu'il
s'est passé depuis la dernière fois ?
- Oui, ben du coup voilà,
j'étais retournée chez ma mère.
Ensuite après je suis retournée à Paris,
j'ai accouché à Paris.
Ils ont fait plein de tests sur elle et sur moi,
pour voir si jamais je ne me droguais plus,
voir si jamais ma fille n'avait pas
de trace de drogue,
si elle n'avait pas de manque.
Et donc ils ont vu qu'en fait
elle n'avait rien du tout,
elle était tout à fait normale,
donc du coup ils me l'ont laissée.
On va te laver, hein ?
Bah ouais.
Je vais d'abord faire couler le bain,
parce que je vous explique,
hôtel du 115, c'est hôtel du 115.
J'ai fabriqué un système,
c'est à la "one again",
j'avoue, mais voilà,
j'ai coupé et en fait vous voyez,
ça se met comme ça,
voilà l'eau elle est chaude là.
J'applique vraiment bien tout ce qu'on
m'a dit à la maternité et tout.
Tu sais je ne suis pas douce dans la vie,
avec rien, sauf avec elle.
C'est elle qui m'a appris à être douce,
c'est elle qui m'a appris
à prendre un petit peu de patience.
Bon, il n'y a que pour elle que
j'ai de la patience je précise.
Faut pas qu'elle attrape froid.
- Et comment tu réagirais si jamais,
par exemple,
elle consommait du crack à l'adolescence
ou des choses comme ça ?
- J'irais la rechercher.
Souvent je pense à tout ça.
Je me dis : "Putain, si jamais..."
Tu sais le karma.
Si jamais il reprend...
En fait, je crois que...
enfin je ne crois pas, je suis sûre,
qu'il y a plein de choses que je ne ferais pas
du tout comme mes parents.
Chérie !
Tu fais des câlins à maman ?
Non, il ne faut pas pleurer.
Je t'aime.
J'ai peur que quand ma fille grandisse,
ben...
elle me pose des questions par rapport à ça.
- Et qu'est-ce que tu vas lui
répondre du coup ?
- Ben je vais lui dire que voilà,
maman,
elle avait un moment de sa vie
où elle était perdue.
Jusque quand elle
a appris qu'elle était enceinte,
ben elle a eu l'impression de se retrouver,
grâce à elle.
Ben on va descendre manger une pizza, non ?
C'est toi qui payes, t'as dit,
j'ai pas pris de sous !
Tu viens ?
- Ouais, c'est pour ça que j'ai
changé mes cheveux.
Il y a beaucoup de gens
qui me reconnaissent dans la rue,
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup.
Ils me disaient : "Ah t'as arrêté ?"
Ou alors : "Ah c'est pas toi
la fille enceinte qui prend du crack ?"
Franchement... j'ai tout eu.
Et une fois j'étais super contente,
elles m'ont dit : "Oui, t'as arrêté,
j'espère que t'as pas recommencé
parce que t'es revenue à Paris.
On est super fières, on est super contentes,
franchement t'es géniale,
on t'adore."
J'étais trop contente.
Merci.
- Est-ce que c'est difficile
de se libérer d'une addiction ?
- C'est assez difficile de se libérer
d'une addiction,
parce que sans cesse, en fait,
même encore à l'heure actuelle,
je ne vous mens pas, il y a des fois,
où mon cerveau, enfin je ne sais pas...
Ouais je crois que c'est mon cerveau...
qui me dit : "Écoute avant
t'étais à cette dose-là,
une dose ça te ferait pas de mal."
Enfin, voilà, j’ai des envies
qui passent en fait.
Mais pas plus que ça et puis
elles sont de moins en moins fortes
avec le temps.
La ville, avant, je la voyais grise,
Paris, je le voyais que gris, et maintenant,
ben je vois tout en couleurs.
Voilà, c'est simple.
Je suis pressée qu'elle court, comme ça.
Tu veux...
Il y a pas tout en entier,
on a mangé déjà un petit peu,
mais ne vous en faites pas,
on s'est testé, on n'est pas Covid, nous.
Je t'explique,
il y a un livre sur moi qui va sortir,
et je vais distribuer à des gens
qui sont dans la rue.
Si tu veux, avant, j'étais comme toi.
Tu vois.
J'ai 19 ans, mais avant j'étais vraiment...
Depuis mes 13 ans je dormais dehors, tu vois,
et je fumais du crack,
j'étais à la colline, tu vois,
et j'ai eu mon bébé, et c'est ça
qui m'a tout fait arrêter, en fait.
Faites attention à vous.
Quelques semaines plus tôt, il y a
une maison d'édition qui m'a appelée
et qui voulait proposer à Laurie d'écrire
un roman, un roman autobiographique.
Et c'était le rêve de Laurie
depuis très longtemps d'écrire un livre.
Du coup, on a pris
rendez-vous avec l'éditrice.
Gare de l'Est, je connais trop.
Je connais par cœur, j'allais
dans le parking pour fumer et tout.
Ah ici je connais il me semble,
je crois que j'ai été
dans un commissariat pas loin, là.
Ici je connais, c'est l'hôpital machin, là.
Il y a même un truc psychiatrique, je pense,
où il y a des médicaments gratuits même.
- Ben... Je me dis que je suis
passée à autre chose, quoi.
- Bonjour Laurie.
- Bonjour.
Merci d'être là,
c'est vraiment gentil,
je suis ravie de vous rencontrer.
De vous rencontrer toutes
les deux, toutes les trois.
- Je peux m'asseoir ?
- Ben oui... au contraire.
- Il a quel âge ?
- Elle a 4 ans et demi,
si je ne me trompe pas.
- J'ai vraiment envie de faire mon livre.
J'ai vraiment envie.
- Mais c'est vraiment important.
- Et est-ce que je dois mettre mon enfance ?
Ou je dois mettre que les épisodes dehors ?
- L'idée, c'est un peu tout.
Mais si vous en avez envie.
- Oui, oui.
- De quoi vous avez envie de parler,
et ce que vous avez envie de dire
et ce que vous avez envie de transmettre.
Il y a un message très fort à adresser
à tous les jeunes qui ont plongé,
à tous les enfants aussi,
qui sont en galère et qui
subissent ce que vous avez subi,
qui ont des problèmes de famille,
des attouchements,
Donc c'est aussi libérer la parole
pour que quand les enfants sont petits,
puissent avoir des gens à qui parler,
n'aient pas peur de parler pour éviter d'arriver
à se faire du mal.
- Ouais, parce que je me scarifiais
et tout ça, avant.
La solution pour me tuer
à petit feu, ben c'était de me droguer
parce que sur l'instant, j'étais bien.
Et à peine deux secondes après,
j'étais toute... Comment dire ?
J'étais dans le speed, dans le stress,
j'avais toutes mes angoisses qui me
retombaient dessus et c'était un truc de fou.
Mais le moment où je tirais dessus,
c'était là que j'étais bien.
J'avais vraiment envie d'écrire
un bouquin là-dessus.
Parce que, voilà, comme ça, ça sort.
C'est plus en moi.
Il y a beaucoup en moi.
Et... voilà.
- C'est très courageux.
- Et en plus... enfin, je crois que j'écris bien.
- Oui.
- Depuis toute petite, j'écris.
Et rien que d'écrire,
ben ça me libère en fait,
je ne sais pas expliquer, ça...
ça sort et ça se met sur une feuille,
et c'est plus là-dedans quoi.
Merci Laurie, à très bientôt.
Qu'est-ce que tu cherches ?
- Je cherche mon livre.
Tu l'as trouvé, déjà, Camille ?
Oh lala, il y a beaucoup de livres,
moi je ne sais pas...
Oh ! Trop bien.
C'est mon histoire quoi.
En fait, j'ai pas l'impression que c'est moi.
J'ai pas l'impression que c'est moi.
Je ne sais pas expliquer...
En fait c'est...
c'est tellement quelque chose de ouf.
Je triple, je double.
Ah !
Beh là, je me sens toute...
toute en coton quoi.
Toute défoncée, sans être défoncée.
- Ouais, je me sens toute bien,
mais j’ai peur aussi.
J’ai peur parce que toute œuvre,
que ce soit un livre, un film, ou quoi,
il y a des critiques.
- Il y aura toujours des gens
pour critiquer ton parcours.
Mais peu de gens sont capables
d’avoir un parcours
et de se relever comme tu l’as fait.
Donc soit fière de toi,
t’inquiètes pas des critiques.
Y’en aura toujours pour critiquer.
Voilà.
Mais vraiment, soit fière de toi.
- Merci.
- Nous on l’est.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour !
Bah.
Tu viens ?
- Ouais, carrément !
- Ça va ?
- Ça va et toi ?
*Imitation bruit de moteur*
C’est le rallye mon cœur !
- Bah, on se connaît...
Je m’en souviens.
Tu étais tout le temps cloîtrée dans la tente.
- Je te jure c’est...
- Tu sortais juste pour aller...
- Juste pour aller tapiner, c’était l’enfer.
- Bah, ça me fait plaisir de la voir comme ça.
Ça me fait super plaisir parce que...
Elle en a vécu des trucs
et elle est plus jeune que moi.
C’est la preuve qu’on peut s’en sortir.
Moi, je me suis pas
totalement sortie du produit,
donc c’est une vraie inspiration pour moi quoi.
Voilà ton livre !
- Merci beaucoup !
Je vais le dévorer !
Ça me fait trop, trop plaisir !
Je te souhaite que du bonheur.
Et ça me fait trop plaisir de te voir
comme ça.
- Fais attention à toi, d’accord ?
- Ouais !
- Ça me fait plaisir et
ça me donne beaucoup de courage.
Laurie, c’est vraiment une miraculée.
Et franchement, c’est vraiment incroyable
pour moi
de l’avoir vue parcourir tout ce chemin,
en seulement 2 ans.
C’est vraiment une page qui se tourne,
pour elle évidemment,
mais pour moi aussi un petit peu quoi.
Et si vous êtes intéressés de savoir
comment j’ai rencontré Laurie
la première fois,
comment je suis arrivée
sur la colline du crack
et comment j’ai travaillé là-bas,
et aussi comment j’ai entretenu
le contact avec Laurie au fil des ans,
je raconte toutes les coulisses des tournages
dans une vidéo
sur ma chaîne YouTube personnelle.
Voilà, j’espère que le reportage vous a plû.
À très bientôt !